Speaking of rocks and foundations, we are continuing our series this morning,
which we're calling firm foundation. A few weeks ago we saw Jesus promised to
build his church, and he builds his church on a firm foundation. He is the
cornerstone, but he's also given us the firm foundation of his word. And there's
some foundational truths in his word which we're going through. And we've
been going through our statement of faith, essentially, looking at the kind of
major doctrines that we see in Scripture. Certainly not everything, but some of
these foundational truths. In this moment, or this morning, rather, we've come to
our statement on sin. So we've moved from a really encouraging story to how I'm
going to talk to you about sin for the next 30 minutes. Our statement of faith
says it this way, it says sin is any act or attitude that is contrary to
God's moral law, whether conscious or unconscious. We believe that through the
fall of man, sin entered the world and man is now born into sin. This sin
separates man from his holy Creator. And the place we're going to go to see what
Scripture teaches about sin is Romans chapter 5. So if you've got a Bible,
please turn there with me to Romans chapter 5. If you need to look at a
worship guide or scripture elsewhere, it's on the back of your worship guide,
our reading. But we'll be looking at Romans chapter 5 and also kind of dipping
in the other places in Scripture too to see what it says about this important
subject of sin. So we'll read Romans 5 verses 12 to 17. Therefore, just as
sin came into the world through one man in death through sin. So death
spread to all men because all sinned. For sin indeed was in the world before the
law was given, but sin is not counted where there is no law. Yet death range
from Adam to Moses, even over those who sinning was not like the
transgression of Adam, who was a type of the one who was to come. But the
free gift is not like the trespass. For if many died through one man's
trespass, much more have the grace of God and the free gift by the grace
of that one man Jesus Christ abounded for many. And the free gift is not like
the result of that one man sin. For the judgment following one trespass
brought condemnation. But the free gift following many trespasses brought
justification. For if because of one man's trespass, death reigned
through that one man, much more will those who receive the abundance of
grace and the free gift of righteousness reign in life through the
one man Jesus Christ. Let's pray.
Lord, we thank you so much for your word. And we thank you for the
encouragement of your word. Lord, we also want to thank you for the
warnings of your word. Lord, how you speak to us, not just about the
positive things as it were, but you speak to us about the problems that
we have as well. And Lord, I pray that as we look at this difficult
subject of sin this morning, Lord, I pray that we would know you speaking
to us. Lord, help us to see both the horrors of the sin, but also the
glories of the remedy that is found in Jesus. We pray this in his name.
Amen. Well, back in 2014, our family moved from Burkina Faso, West
Africa, where we had been serving as missionaries back to England.
And when we got back, I mean, there was lots of kind of bumps along the
road. But one of them is we had to go to the hospital pretty quickly.
And it was because Gideon was really, really unwell to the point of us
needing an ambulance to come to the house and transport him and the rest
of us to the to the hospital. And we just kind of it was a blur as
we kind of got into the door and he was taken to a bed and all the
rest. And then as he's finally starting to settle a little bit, we then
started to look at the posters that were on the walls around the hospital.
You see, in 2014, it was right in the middle of the Ebola crisis in West
Africa. And so there were cases of thousands of cases of Ebola.
And many people were dying.
And Ebola is this violent, awful virus.
And and on these posters, it kind of gave the symptoms of this,
but it also said, if you have recently returned from West Africa,
notify staff immediately.
And so we kind of said, OK, I guess we've got to say there hadn't been any
reported cases in Burkina Faso.
We knew that part, but we thought we didn't need to say this.
And so we told them and the nurse who was with us, you could just
immediately see the kind of blood drain from her face.
And she was absolutely horrified.
And later on, people had to come check to make sure she was OK.
And turns out, getting did not have Ebola.
So praise God for that.
But they were not going to take any chances.
So they knew how serious that would be.
Not to get totally sidetracked.
We had another friend who traveled back to New Zealand around the same time
because he had a broken toe and a bit of an infection and a broken toe.
And they literally met him and hazmat suits and kind of put him
quarantined him and it made the national news in New Zealand.
They were not taking any chances with Ebola.
Well, all things considered, you know, you can understand the extreme
cautions when it comes to viruses like Ebola, because I mean, they cause
suffering and death and they're highly contagious.
So it's right to inform about things like that and even warn about things like that.
And scripture speaks to us clearly about how deadly sin is.
And sometimes scripture actually speaks about sin in terms of it being like a disease.
There are different illustrations that are used, but that is certainly one of them
could showing us how seriously we must take it.
It's a deadly disease that has infected us all.
So it is right to inform and to even warn about the deadliness of sin.
But the good news is that there is a cure for our sin problem.
Mark, Chapter two in verse 17, Jesus said this, he said,
those who are well have no need of a physician, but those who are sick.
I came not to call the righteous, but sinners to repentance.
So if you're going to be cured by Jesus, you have to be ready to admit
that you've been infected with the disease.
You have to be ready to admit that you are not righteous,
but rather in this category of a sinner.
So we're going to look at this.
So two questions, simple questions.
One, what is sin and what is the solution to sin?
So what do most people think of when they think of the word sin?
It's not a really popular word in society, but I'd imagine most people think of
probably the not just the kind of everyday kind of wrong thing we do,
but particularly egregious acts like that are really bad,
that we all kind of agree are really bad like crimes, that kind of thing.
We might use sin in that category.
Scripture is clear about what sin is, and it's it's it's far more comprehensive
than just the worst things that we can think about.
And the biblical author that gives the most thorough treatment of sin
is the apostle Paul, especially in the book of Romans,
which we're looking at this morning.
Over 50 times in the book, Paul mentions sin or some other form of that word.
And several times he mentions it in the passage that I read just a moment ago.
So let's return to verse 12 begins,
therefore, just as sin came into the world through one man and death through sin.
So death spread to all men because all sinned.
So let's look at this problem and how and how deep it goes.
All right. So first of all, let's let's kind of look at a definition of sin.
So what is meant by the word sin?
Well, a good place to get a working definition of sin would have been
the men's event last Sunday.
And I don't mean just the awful things that took place at this men's event
or the sickness that took place afterwards.
You can ask Matt Green if you want to know all about that.
I wouldn't recommend it, but we were clay shooting.
And it was clear, like as we were there, kind of like shooting away,
like there were some there's some marksmen among us that really
shined on the day and I mean hitting them every single time.
And then there were people like me who had no business holding a gun.
There are people just had no idea and we were there happy to participate.
Well, the Greek word for sin is literally missing the mark.
Like you look at like classic Greek literature or even like the Greek
translation of the Old Testament, you see like if somebody like throws a javelin
and they miss, that's the word sin, missing the mark.
You can look at lots of examples like that, but you can imagine the bull's
eye and you're aiming at it and you you miss over here.
So what's the target that we have missed?
Well, last Sunday, we looked at humanity and what it means to be human.
We saw that the purpose of humanity.
And so God created us as his image bearers that we might reflect his glory
and live as his representatives in the world.
And his glory is reflected in our in our character as we follow him as our king.
Well, did we do that?
Well, no, right from the beginning, you see Adam and Eve are given this
command to follow like will they represent the king by following his commands?
No, instead of choosing God's rule, they choose self rule and they immediately
break the command of God.
They miss the mark of what they were made for.
They weren't glorifying their king, but rather choosing to go their own way
and breaking his commands.
And we've been following the same direction ever since.
And so this is this is what you get in say Romans three twenty three,
probably the most well known verse about sin for all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God.
Sometimes we think about that first part because it says that we've all sinned,
we're all sinners, but then we forget the second part.
What it means to sin is to fall short of God's glory to not
hit the mark that we were called to to aim for as God's image bearers.
We want to rule our own lives.
I want to do things my own way.
Thank you very much.
And in that kind of way of life, we reflect God.
We fail to reflect God's glory.
You know, when claims are made about what's right and what's wrong,
you know, it's important to ask by what standard.
You know, nobody in their right mind wants to live in a world
where everything goes, where just anything goes.
We know there has to be standards of what is right and what is wrong.
But the question is, how do we determine what is right and what is wrong?
At the end of the day, everybody has beliefs about that.
But some people may just not admit to have beliefs about that.
What a lot of people mean by right and wrong, they have to logically,
they have to say, this is what I feel is right or what I feel is wrong,
because they do not have objective grounding for their morality.
So how do we find out what's right and wrong?
Well, Scripture teaches that we have a righteous God
who is the standard of what is right and wrong.
His glory is that standard.
God himself is the standard.
But that puts us in a predicament.
If God's holiness, like His righteousness, is the standard of what is right
and what is wrong, then we all miss the mark.
It doesn't matter if you're a squeaky clean, every Sunday Christian or whatever,
or you're the kind of worst person you could imagine.
We all miss the mark because none of us perfectly reflect the righteousness of God.
You know, if there was a ladder, say, and like at the bottom of the ladder was,
say, Hitler and like near the top of the ladder was, say, Mother Teresa or somebody like that.
You look at the ladder and say, well, where would you put yourself?
You know, we might think, well, maybe not that good.
Maybe I'm three quarters of the way up or halfway or something like that.
Like, where would you put God on the ladder?
The answer is like, well, he wouldn't be on the ladder.
Like you have to get up to the sun or some other galaxy or something like that.
He is far above us in terms of his own righteousness.
So we all fall well short.
We're all sinners.
All right, the definition.
We miss the mark of God's glory.
How deep does the problem go, though?
Like how serious is this?
Well, sin is, let's give us three things here.
One, sin is definitely seen in our actions.
Our actions are spoken of as being sinful.
So God gives us this moral standard by giving us his word and sin is going against his word,
both in the things that we do or the things that we fail to do.
You know, we've seen Adam and Eve given a command.
They break the command, right?
So they do something that they're not to do.
The people of Israel are later on than given the 10 commandments and that the moral law there encapsulates this kind of objective moral standard.
That we look at to see what is right and what is wrong, what is righteous, what is sinful.
And when we look at the 10 commandments, you know, how it reflects God's righteousness.
And if you give them a fair reading, you can't help but admitting that you've broken them.
I mean, I've certainly broken them.
Like who among us has never told a lie before?
And you get a passage like James 2.10 in the New Testament says if we've broken one of those commandments,
it's like we've broken all of those commandments.
So upon closer inspection of these commands though, we see that it's not just to do with our actions, our sin.
Like yes, we can talk about sinful actions, but our sin also is our desires too.
We can have sinful desires.
So what is the last of the 10 commandments?
Anybody remember?
You shall not covet, isn't it?
Well, coveting, that's our desires.
Instead of being content with God and what He has seen fit to give us, we desire more.
And that is covetousness.
That's a problem of the heart.
You know, in the Garden of Eden, shade was cast upon the truthfulness of God's Word.
And then Eve sees the fruit and she desires it.
And then she acts upon those desires.
So Adam and Eve's sin is seen in both their desire as well as their action.
So sin doesn't begin with merely doing something that is forbidden.
It begins by believing a lie about God, you know, that He is withholding something good from you
and setting your desire on something that He has not given you.
When you get to the teaching of Jesus, it's abundantly clear that sin has to do with our desires as well.
So Matthew chapter 5 verses 20 and 21, he says,
You've heard that instead of old, you shall not murder and whoever murders will be liable to judgment.
But I say to you that everyone who is angry with his brother will be liable to judgment.
We're not just held accountable for acting out upon our anger and like in murder,
held accountable for the anger itself.
He says the same thing about adultery and lust in Matthew 5 as well.
So it's not just the act of adultery but lusting after someone.
So true righteousness isn't just external conformity to God's rules,
but loving Him with all your heart and loving your neighbor as yourself
and then that comes through in our actions.
So sin is self-rule.
It is a rebellion of the heart that is then made visible in our actions.
By the time you get to Romans 5, you see that the problem of sin goes even deeper
than our actions and our desires.
This is the third thing in terms of the depths of sin.
It's talking about our very nature.
Sin isn't just something that affects us when we are awake, but when we are asleep.
What do I mean by that? I mean we are sinners by nature.
That's what it teaches here.
Romans 5 speaks about the devastating effects of Adam's sin.
So sin comes into the world through one man and death through sin.
And so death spread to all because all sinned.
So sin comes into the world through Adam, but it doesn't just affect him.
Sin and death then spread to every person who follows.
And this isn't just speaking about death.
It's not just talking about physical death that includes that.
It's talking about spiritual death as well.
Being cut off from God from the very source of life itself.
When it says that death spread to all because all sinned,
it doesn't just mean that we all kind of just follow Adam's example in sin like he did.
So it's not just our individual sins being addressed here.
The reading of it seems like it could be reading in that way.
It's not just that we are mistakenly following Adam's bad example.
Here's what it's saying. There's a sense in which when Adam sinned, we all sinned.
When Adam died, we all shared in the death penalty that followed.
So you go down to say the second half of verse 15.
Or kind of in the middle of it says the free gift is not like the trespass,
but then it says if many died through one man's trespass.
Adam trespasses, he breaks the law and then the many died because of his sin.
Or you go down to say the start of verse 19.
For as by one man's disobedience, the many were made sinners.
So Adam disobeys and then because of that, many are made sinners.
That's talking about all of humanity here.
Okay, so we are all sinners because of Adam's sin and we all share in that penalty for sin.
But if you look kind of going back up, if you look, you have that statement in verse 12 about our sinfulness.
And then verse 13 to 14, you kind of see an argument that flows from that.
So as we've already seen, Adam violated a specific command that he was given and death comes as a result.
And then later on, God gives his law to his people and the people are held accountable for breaking the law.
But Paul makes the case here that even without the law and the knowledge of sin that comes with the law,
the results of Adam's sin are still present in each one of us.
So we're all sinners because of him.
Death spreads to everyone that follows.
You know, a couple chapters after the fall.
We've got this, you know, where it talks about Adam having a son and his likeness, Seth.
But then you have this kind of chronicles the generations that follow Adam.
But each one has this refrain, and he died, and he died, and he died.
You're seeing that what happened with Adam and Eve is now spreading throughout humanity.
So let's go to verse 13 again.
So it says, for example, like sin is not counted when there is no law.
So what that's not saying is not saying that we're treated as sinless as long as we don't have the law.
So like you go back to Romans 2, Paul already has written about how the law of God is written on our hearts.
And we break that.
It's not like as long as a rule isn't there, there is no sin there.
No sin is definitely there, and so are the results.
You know, way before God wrote, you know, thou shalt not kill.
You've got Cain killing his brother Abel, and he still held accountable for his sinful actions.
And there are plenty of other examples throughout pre-law of people being held accountable for their sin
and the devastating consequences of sin.
So what's it saying then?
What's it saying is that once the law is put into place, the defiance of our sin even goes a step further.
Our rebellious sinful nature sees those objective lines that are drawn.
We say, okay, that's the law. Okay, that's exactly what sin is. I'm still going to cross it.
I say it's not just in our nature. We see exactly what we're doing and we still transgress the law.
So the results of Adam's sin is still present in each one of us today.
Like we all cross those lines willfully.
And you get in kind of verses 15 to 21 in Romans 5 and the rest of the chapter were repeatedly told us through one man's sin.
They were all made sinners and we received this judgment because of our sin.
So Adam began with a clean slate, but put it simply, we do not.
So you have this in Psalm 51 where David says in verse 5,
He says,
Ephesians 2-3 says that we were by nature children of wrath, even as others, centers by nature.
That doesn't mean the image of God is not present within all of us because it is as we saw last week.
And it doesn't mean we're all as bad as we could be. None of us are.
But what happens when you wash a red sock with all your white clothes?
It affects the whole. The whole thing is like pink.
The same is true with sin. It affects us all in every part of us.
So Adam, our representative head, if you will, fell and with him came the fall of all that followed,
including us, to put it plainly.
We don't sin because we are rather we're not sinners because we sin.
We sin because we're sinners. Do you see the difference there?
We sin because we are sinners. And you might be sitting here thinking like,
how important is this? Is this some like ethereal theological discussion?
Like how many angels can dance on the head of a pen of a needle or something like that?
It's not. This is very serious and it's very personal to all of us.
Because if you misdiagnose a disease, you'll probably give the wrong cure.
Like if the problem is just our behavior, well, change your behavior.
Like you can just follow these rules and have a new way of life here.
We have to see the depths of it so that we see the true solution that we really need.
Alright, so what is the solution? That's that second question.
Well, after Adam and Eve sinned, their eyes were open.
They saw that they were naked and they came up with their own solution.
Do you remember what it was? They got fig leaves and sowed them together.
They created this covering. They hid themselves from God.
So that wasn't the right solution. Well, God then gives this temporary solution.
He gives the promise about becoming Savior, but he also makes animal skins for them.
So their sin is covered through the death of another.
So they're covered. That was a temporary covering.
It was not the final solution.
So what's the final solution?
It's for us to be in Christ. It's for us to have our lives hidden in Him.
It's to be given a new life in the one who died for us.
To be clothed in His righteousness. To have a new nature.
Alright, so let's see this in Romans 5.
Alright, so sins the problem, Christ is the cure.
But let's see it here. Verse 17, we see, or verse 14, rather,
that Adam was a type of the one who was to come.
So he's a type or a figure or a picture of someone who is to come.
So in Adam, we have this kind of picture that is almost like a negative.
Like you take, you used to take film to go get it developed and whatever.
And you see the negative and it can be really ghostly.
But then you can also get the really beautiful picture that comes from it.
So Adam is a type, a picture of Christ to come.
But he's like the kind of ghostly negative.
But then we're going to get this beautiful photo that will follow.
In Adam we see the ugliness of sin and its consequences.
But it's pointing us to the beauty of Christ and the good that He is going to bring about.
He points forward to a true and better Adam that is to come.
So see the contrast.
So Adam takes something for himself.
But Christ, the ruler comes to graciously give to others.
Adam's sin results in condemnation.
But Christ's righteousness brings about justification or being declared righteous.
Adam disobeyed and many were made sinners.
Christ obeyed and many are made righteous.
Adam's sin resulted in the reign of death.
But Christ's actions brought about the reign of life.
2 Corinthians 5, 21 says it in this way about Jesus.
He who knew no sin.
So Jesus is not affected by the sin that we are affected by.
And yet says he who knew no sin was made sin for us.
Why? Why did he take our sin upon himself?
Why did he die for us?
That we might be made the righteousness of God in him.
So he took all of our disease upon himself, that sin,
that we might be given his life and his righteousness.
So we need to see the depths of our sin.
Yes, that we might know how desperate our need is.
But another reason we need to see the depths of our sin is so that we see the wondrous reality of what Christ has done for us.
What he took upon himself when he died on the cross.
And this amazing righteousness that we get instead of our sin.
So Jesus is perfect. He perfectly reflects the glory of God.
He took our sin. We might receive his righteousness.
He conquered death as our representative had.
And now he reigns in life.
And our life is found in him.
So are you in Adam or are you in Christ?
Now, let's make a quick comment here.
Our radical individualism in the West makes it hard for this to understand.
Like, am I really accountable for what Adam did?
And I don't really understand what it means for Christ to be my head and to have life in him.
We understand something of like individual responsibility, sure,
but we're not so sure about being connected to others.
But a lot of you were celebrating yesterday evening.
Not everybody.
Because of the game that happened or game, whichever one you were watching.
And you know when it comes to, say, you get to the team that you are supporting.
Like, you're a big fan of them.
And you're on the edge of your seat and say it comes down,
like in the last second, to one final goal.
And then your guy pulls through and there's the touchdown or the field goal or whatever.
And game is over. The crowd goes wild.
You jump up with them like you're at home, but you're still jumping.
You're really excited.
And what's everybody saying?
We won, we won. You say we won.
The reality is you didn't do anything.
You sat at home eating cheese dip and you're the one saying we won.
But it's also right to say we won.
Because we all share in that together. We're part of that.
And so we're looking at Adam. You see this horrible defeat.
Yes, we all went down with him.
You see this amazing victory that Jesus brings about conquering sin and death.
And when you put your faith in him, you can declare yes,
we are righteous in him.
Sin no longer has dominion over me.
I'm under the reign of Christ and his righteousness and his life.
So his victory belongs to me.
So Adam, our representative had failed and we fell with him.
But Christ succeeded and through faith in him, we can call his righteousness and his life our own.
We can join in the song of 1 Corinthians 15.
Where is your death? Where is your victory?
Oh death, where is your sting?
The sting of death is sin and the power of sin is the law.
But thanks be to God who gives us the victory through our Lord Jesus Christ.
So the question isn't are you a sinner or not?
The question is whether or not you are in Adam or whether or not you are in Christ.
The way to know you are in Christ is by putting your faith in him.
Putting your trust in him.
So we've seen some things about sin but we've seen some glorious truths about Christ.
So as we wrap up, how should we respond?
Well first of all, receive the gift of life that is offered to you in Jesus.
Hold out the empty hands of faith because he's ready to forgive you,
to reconcile you to himself and to give you eternal life,
to give you his own righteousness if you receive it as a gift.
And the second thing, if you have received that gift is rely upon the grace
that you have been given in Christ in the fight against sin.
So we're not to make peace with sin, we're to go to war with sin.
We do that not in our own strength but in Christ's strength
because he's already defeated our sin on the cross.
And then lastly, rejoice in what Christ has done for you
and the hope that you have in him.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much for speaking to us so clearly in your word about the problem of our sin
and it's not easy for us to hear.
Lord, we thank you that you give us the bad news that we might be able to hear the good news.
Lord, I pray that you'd help us to see the seriousness of sin and the deadliness of it.
Lord, I pray that instead of just living in the guilt of that and the shame of that
or trying to fix ourselves, Lord, I pray that you would help us to run to Jesus
that we would receive the grace that you have shown us in him.
Or that we would know your forgiveness.
Or that we would know the joy of being reconciled to you.
We would know your presence with us in the fight against sin.
So Lord, we thank you so much for what you've done for us in Jesus.
I pray that you would help us to look away from our sinfulness to his righteousness
and his name we pray. Amen.